[Music]
and come on China what you're trying to
do dude I mean if I don't know hulls no
no I love donut holes oh you do Timbits
they're called donut holes in Timbits
so I don't wait here in America we call
them don't know that should be a term
yeah you donut hole that's why I
originally thought China faces backlash
by using live pigs as crash-test dummies
China suppose not like the most because
yeah but they're usually you see you
should probably kill them first for you
but then how will you know if the car
crash will kill them if they're already
dead
yeah the US has been doing it just fine
for a while using exactly ads but
they're like Honda would show like so
many can you turn your crash-test
dummies into bacon that's true all right
they get into a car crash we can see
like which part will go where like if
the arm will go that way we can see at
the exact moment at which the life
leaves there I put a little bit more
padding there straightforward how much
of an impact will it how much of an
impact will it take for they had to go
right through the window right right I
think that the ejection of a pig I heard
the front of the windows very solid data
point right there's a line for everybody
though I mean you got like you know the
vegans over here you have like meters
over yeah so what is the line for you
guys because most times when people like
you know kill a cockroach or like an ant
they even give a [ __ ] but then it starts
getting into like fish and it's like
maybe I care and then they gets into
like mammals and like I really care and
then II because it's like the dogs and
cats knows like [ __ ] you I think I'll be
away I think bugs are one thing once you
start to get any fish I feel like you
should just not try not to be cruel with
it leave you're gonna kill something
just you know be quick be quick with it
you know make an executive decision yeah
move on well that's exactly the opposite
of what they did here
China boom boom let me just tell you
seven young pigs have died seven babes
two
okay I expressed young because
apparently these young pigs there are
net anatomic structures most similar to
human six euros we doing tests for
seatbelt children for six-year-old Oh
toddler seat two there just to give you
guys take that bacon joke back Sean yeah
just kidding news dude that's pretty
[ __ ] gnarly do can you imagine being
the battery looks something from like an
old test book there we go back in 1920s
back to test on Pig we don't do that
anymore
like wasn't there that one car
commercial there's like a pig inside
like the car he's like smiling and like
he's not the hamsters no no he's like
it's a Geico course yes yeah it's so sad
now so before the pigs were even put
into their tests mm-hmm the young pigs
were starved for 24 hours this sentence
is so out of place it's just inserted
here almost just like sir you should
know it very says the young pigs were
starved for 24 hours at least in the
last meal and denied water for six hours
before - no you can't wait for what
reason like what was their testing
they're like all because the blah blah
blah it doesn't say it jumps
automatically talking about the
six-year-olds after that cuz
six-year-olds don't drink water before
it wasn't a weight thing maybe they're
telling it the weight I think there are
probably what car company they were
testing for know it what should i what
aren't you many use car companies anyway
you know they have their own
I never even been they never tell you
it's bad communism yeah but um I assume
this is like a whistle blower thing I
don't think China's not gonna come out
of it all my back course not but yeah
these so yeah back to I was saying seven
young pigs were killed during these
tests there all of them dead they were
strapped no no no not seven died eight
offered injuries so over dozen over a
dozen pigs were uses they were strapped
on the sleds and slammed into walls at
30 miles an hour
what simulated crashing yeah other
suffered injuries so the research did
bring out stuff research you know what
you sound like right now you sound like
the Nazis during the 1940s with eugenics
right now cuz you're like well your
chest workout and we like he's reporting
on the one app he's not you're not
feeding like Brandon's like you know
absolutely should do it again he's like
well actually it works hey Chinese
people pride myself in Chinese they at
least when we eat the pig leave every
single yeah yeah but I would never like
come on dude why would we starve the pig
if you're gonna do this like like I said
it they're going the total opposite way
of what are the stars like clarified
they're alive they have bleeding broken
bones I'm trying to make the point of
they were alive when they were in the
car yeah okay at the end of the results
and there was mix some time some got
injured experiment I feel like there are
probably a live for a portion of the
time afterward but then they decide to
put them out of their misery and then
just like no I think I'm gonna probably
died in the guy died on impact because
they would have recorded it as like
great success they were only mildly made
so whatever starving them as part of it
only because if you put food in their
systems it's like it changes the results
built-in body weight
you're out of fat in the slush there's
just got to be Canada we're trying to
rationalize it baby they store film
because no it's wrong no no it is wrong
but I'm like you like you said you can
at least let him have a last meal you
know think they're gonna do [ __ ]
like that wait so this is so they chose
these pigs because they replicate six
year old yeah so in case you were
wondering
after the crashes they found lungs of
these six year olds were most frequently
injured followed by the spleens and
delivers gotcha in crash I guess for
these six year olds the lungs go first
apparently so really what they're trying
to say is they make shitty seatbelts I
feel like this article was written kind
of like more of like for shock factor I
mean like why would you say six year old
pigs and like saying like find me a
non-biased journalist like our article
and then and now read it sure it's just
like I'm sorry that's pretty tough to
like it is why really choosing young
pigs because it relates closest to the
six-year-olds you know on top of that
they were giving an anesthetic to reduce
excitement and stress beforehand well I
guess the imitator sedated somewhat I
guess cuz that's [ __ ] cuz maybe when
you're strapped in if they're freaking
the [ __ ] out dude screaming dude do this
PETA exist in China this is according to
Peter but Peter reported they found like
anesthetics or they they claim that PETA
is in China this damn it feels like
worldwide isn't it is a whistleblower
this is from the independent from the UK
but they did say Peter they report on it
okay look don't wanna hurt Peter like
goddammit yeah cuz you're like oh it's
like literal opposite a little bit
because I know that Peter likes to like
overdramatic sighs exactly
like yeah a little real doesn't that's
why I said earlier because in this
article okay if it was written another
way I'd agree but then I'm like
something just seems so off about this
that like oh there's six year just like
security humans I'm so you know they're
also starved for 24 I'm like why did I
need to like know I still take problem
with the fact that they're alive ethical
like that's still pretty unethical and
that causes unneeded suffering to your
you know analogs or whatever because I
know they'll like you know we
experimental mice all the time yeah
right but they're like there are like
certain procedures to go through to like
make sure that their the my suffer as
least as possible before you're
conducting these tests and stuff so I
don't know it doesn't sound like they
were really like how do you guys feel
about this in general like testing on
animals and what what line crosses cuz
you know you know the progress of is
that we sometimes get like no cures for
humans in if I let's say your kid like
has cancer and they're like oh we have
to test this monk you know yeah to save
your kid would you be like nah you guys
I do right I do believe in like
evolution and like Darwinism and do
believe humans are programmed to be more
intelligent yeah no I think that's just
such as facts really yeah it's natural
selection of course I would love to work
towards not using live animal rest but
like you say in that scenario if it's
you know even if it's like my human
friend over like a pig or a monkey right
like I am gonna pick my human friend
just because I have a different
connection to them yeah I don't think I
don't think I can wait like human lives
an animal lives on the same level
yeah for me like there still is a
halfsies now survival the fittest at
every aspect of life but then like if it
means curing cancer and like yes yeah it
sucks it sucks as it seems like we have
to like go through a few monkeys you
know but I mean okay so to play devil's
advocate here isn't it the same as I'm
just trying to make sure that people's
kids are protected from car accidents so
that's why I'm testing it on these pigs
it doesn't seem to be live I don't think
that it needs to be live that's the
thing I think that like if you look at
the u.s. if you look at other countries
that do plenty of [ __ ] crashes
do sony crash-test there's a ton of
[ __ ] data force sensors and auto
stuff that you can do that does require
why they don't have those force sensors
because I know that they probably they
probably could if they wanted to try but
seem about it yeah I think the reports
here like the US hasn't done any live
like yeah right big-time since 1990
that's pretty goddamn reason is pretty
reasonable
holy [ __ ] sound like past like 20 20
years that we found out pigs are
actually intelligent and like yes our
house that's very funny there's actually
a Netflix documentary series called
explain and they talk about animal
intelligence and then how we like create
their rights based on intelligence it's
really crazy like all that stuff and
then how you even measure intelligence
cuz of different kinds of intelligence
to pay there could be people out there
saying no but like humans aren't as
intelligent as some animals right
ultimately we don't know cuz we can't
like hey let's be VR and go into animals
mine there's no way to communicate with
them yeah but to answer that the
articles argument is that there are like
it's very sophisticated mannequins
nowadays 3d imaging advanced computer
modeling that like for crash tests or
this specific one like technology is
there and where we don't need live
animals that's what they're arguing yeah
but you know if I had to guess China's
just lazy
yeah I think China is lazy but China's
also in a lot of ways just kind of like
well no one else is looking clickin or
some people like it's like that um most
recent study where there was they edited
some genes for a new boy or whatever
which is really unethical wait they
already did it in China because this
[ __ ] doctor was just like I'm just
gonna do it I'm just gonna do it well
like what do you what was he doing like
what was he like
Teddy being out worried I forgot what he
was editing I think it was like just
some feature or whatever like actually
do that for like I call her like that
like today yeah yeah but like I think
the point of the of the why everyone was
so outraged is because it's specifically
outlawed for reasons because they don't
want to open that box but he's just like
he's like [ __ ] I'm just gonna do it
cuz like you know ethics be damned I
feel a certain way about it I'm just
gonna go ahead and do it okay
oh yeah so that question would you do it
like would you test or would you pick
out and say okay this is what I want my
kid to have this is what I that's tricky
ultimately I don't think what I won't
have diseases like sometimes it's just
like the stuff that you've been giving
you learn to work within that mission to
the better person I don't mean sometimes
you become tough yeah I don't know that
I'd want to edit out like certain
features and stuff like that or like
give them a certain high or whatever cuz
it just feels like you just competition
with you know well let you guys yeah
dude you just like let them just yeah
leave it to that fifty-fifty
yeah but if I had my family at a history
of like some particularly deadly disease
that hardness yeah or something that was
like killing like kids would just like
that right out the womb like maybe I'd
start to consider it then but ultimately
like if it's just a feature like oh this
guy's get extra pimples yeah this guy's
gonna have [ __ ] like you know blue
eyes or something like that or this
isn't a very nice house whatever like
it's really like you're kind of born
with what you're born with and you that
Woods that's what makes you interesting
it's like creating your own sim it's
pretty much yeah they have this baton
that
[Music]